ken is in los angeles hi ken welcome to
the ramsey show
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
how can we help
well a bit nervous i'll just do my best
to ask the question
and hopefully get some good life and
financial advice from you
okay um i've been working for myself for
almost 20 years
um in the financial services industry
uh my income over the last few years has
done real well except for the last maybe
year or so
it's been declining in part because of
the
company i work for and represent
is is not doing super great
so i've been working really hard to pay
off the house
uh early we're not in any debt
whatsoever um
other than our our mortgage and uh
we're at a we're at a crossroads my wife
and i and our family as to
whether we should potentially leave
leave los angeles leave california
and move out of state to an area that's
obviously less
expensive to accelerate our
my financial goals and you know my
wife's financial goals i guess as well
even though we're not
always on the on the same page but um or
just to stick it out here and
essentially use the money that i've
saved uh
to pay the house off that we're we're
almost right there to pay the house off
um and instead of paying the house off
use the money to try and stimulate some
some income uh in other ways uh
entrepreneurial ways or something how
much money you got saved about 320 grand
way to go okay so the only reason i
use the phrase in my life stick it out
is there has to be a prize on the other
side of sticking it out
what's the prize on the other side of
sticking it out in los angeles it sounds
like you're just
gonna endure to the end of your life and
then you die
you know that's a good question um you
know i mean if if we were sitting down
with my wife
uh and you um we we would both admit to
to ourselves that
more than likely california is not not
our future
even though this is where we grew up
this is our home obviously there's
the list is really long as to the
reasons why to leave
you occasionally allude to them on
on your program but but no i mean our
kids are
our oldest is in high school um and and
we do
really enjoy the area that we're in he's
got a good set of friends which is
really important
i think you know a good social support
group so
as far as taking it out what i mean by
that is like you know for the next few
years
or so while our oldest get through high
school and then
more unlikely we would be probably
exiting
okay all right and so your oldest is
what you're in high school
he's a sophomore okay
so you either leave now or you leave in
two years uh uh more like four to five
we got a middle schooler oh you're going
to run that all up now that's about
that's about to get through
about to go into high school yeah yeah
i'm curious about something you said a
second ago you said my financial goals
and i guess my wife's financial goals
but you said it separately like y'all
are on the same page what are some of
these conversations
i mean about it yeah so um
complicated but i mean um it's uh
we're not we're not 100 on on you know
i've been listening to
dave your show for four years um
ever since i decided i need to make some
some lifestyle changes
my wife generally speaking is very
supportive of
things we do we have a great marriage
however at the same time
she looks at our situation as like
you know very unique meaning you know
able to pay a house off
an expensive house in los angeles uh at
in in the early 40s um very blessed and
you know she would she misses and i and
i do want to support her i mean we
i've we've sacrificed a lot you know
seeing friends take vacations
um we're not you know our kids are
getting older and she's
it's getting a little bit uh challenging
for her to continue to
i i would say live health poor to some
degree
i think that you guys have been on a
financial planner
tightwad budget and she's over it
yeah yeah you could say that
okay and i am too to be honest but
here's the thing
here's the thing the offset of the kids
being moved
is that your quality of life on a daily
basis
and an annual basis is going to increase
considerably
yeah in other words the kids are going
to go on vacation the kids are
not going to be seeing mom and dad dad
particularly who's pretty much
miserable there uh and and all through
my high school years all i remember was
my dad was miserable
yeah i'm out of there dude
yeah just based on what you're telling
me and i think the impact and i would
move tomorrow
i think the impact on your kid resetting
some friends
kids do it all the time i mean there's
lots of people who move with a kid in
high school
and they survive and uh you know
is it ideal no it's not ideal but are
is there a good set of friends with the
proper value systems that you get
plugged into
in a city that is uh where you can
explore your career options
your wife can be allowed to go on
vacation you guys have got a little
wiggle room in your budget to go out and
do some things that you've not been
doing lifestyle-wise
and you pay cash for a house with 300
000 bucks when you make the move and you
start a new career
it's a new adventure for everyone and
everyone's getting an upgrade in this
model
uh except the kid is getting a bit of a
down
but overall the kid's getting an upgrade
yeah and they may not understand it
first they probably won't but you're
their parent you get to make the
decisions for what's best for the family
and if this is what you and your wife
decide it's best for your family you're
putting all of these yourself
in their life at risk or something to be
different you're just changing high
school
yeah i mean i'm sorry i'm old you are
it's not it's not
get over it you know you'll be all right
you don't you're gonna make it
they will and when they're on the other
side of it they will get to experience
that they just can't see
past friday night right now they're
they're teenagers that's how teenagers
think and act
they'll be glad on the other side of it
and there'll be
but i'm telling you i think the quality
of your family unit i think dr john
baloney would tell us
that the vibe in your house your kids
pick up on the vibe
yeah it'll be overall worth pick up on
the stress that's in the air
they pick up on the disappointment
that's in the air the gritted teeth i'm
gonna
stick it out that's in the air that's
right and so i wouldn't stick it out
yeah
it's done you and your wife are both
done but for different reasons
uh the only thing holding you there is a
sophomore in high school
sophomore in high school gets to go
along on this adventure
that's that's the way it is this is the
ramses we're going to explain it to them
but i mean i'm not being mean or
uncaring you could certainly
you can we can empathize with a young
person's feelings that's not the point
we don't have to be mean about it or
just act like it doesn't matter it does
matter but their upgrade if they turn
their attitudes about this in the right
direction it's gonna
far i mean they're gonna parents who
aren't stressed parents who are living
the dream
lifestyle increases uh you know a
different environment
to live in and i it could be an
adventure yeah and i think when you're
when
you're in the weeds of decisions like
that sometimes it can be so hard to sort
through your options and all the
different variables but even like you
said
which is more important that you keep
the software in high school the middle
school or through the school system or
that you're happy and enjoying every
aspect of your life it sounds like five
years of hell
yeah it's like this is gonna affect
everything when you look at it like that
you go oh
and the only benefit is the kid doesn't
change friend sets right
that's the only thing we're going
through five years of hell so a middle
schooler doesn't change
princess i'm i'm done with this no i
wouldn't do it i wouldn't do it i'm
sorry
hey man i appreciate you it's you got a
good heart you're thinking this through
you wanted some input you got it and
it's probably worth what you paid for it